hello everyone and welcome to today's
session mass cytometry in translational
research
session one and i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i will be your moderator
for today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen today's session
includes three presenters dr shelly
herbridge dr
kara davis and dr bernd bowden-miller
each will present and have a q a
following their individual presentations
i first introduce our first speaker dr
shelly herbridge
a postdoctoral fellow at the university
of texas
md anderson cancer center presenting on
the topic of single
mass cytometry identifying
mechanisms of resistance to
immunotherapy
in aml for complete biography of dr
herbert
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr herbridge welcome you may now begin
your presentation
okay so i would like to thank the
organizers this year for
inviting me to share a little bit of our
work that we're doing
down at md anderson looking at
mechanisms of
resistance to immunotherapy and acute
myeloid leukemia
using single cell mass cytometry
so normal hematopoiesis is classically
described as a hierarchical structure
with the rare hematopoietic stem cells
or hscs
residing at the apex and these hscs are
capable of both
self-renewal as well as differentiating
into more committed progenitor cells
that will ultimately go on to give rise
to the mature cells of both myeloid and
the lymphoid compartments
however in acute myeloid leukemia the
accumulation of mutations
and subsequent genomic instability in
these early stem and myeloid progenitors
can actually halt normal maturation
resulting in what we call the leukemia
stem
cells or lsds that are capable of um
rapidly out producing rapidly producing
abnormal white blood cells
and ultimately out competing the
production of healthy
myeloid as well as lymphoid cells
we know that the frontline standard
chemotherapeutic agents are largely
effective
at eliminating the bulk of disease
driving patients into remission
however most patients will go on to give
rise to deadly relapse leukemia
so our lab is interested in
understanding new therapeutics that will
ultimately
eradicate the complete
leukemia stem cell disease for those
patients especially with
refractory relapse disease
so since the approval of the first
anti-ctla
antibody hit the lumimab in 2011
for a variety of solid tumors
there have been multiple immune
checkpoint inhibitors or icis
targeting molecules such as ctla4 pd1
pdl1 that have had widespread use and
efficacy in solid tumor settings
however the efficacy in the heme
malignancy world remains far more
limited
um with icis receiving approval in only
certain subsets uh
including hodgkin's lymphoma and certain
t-cell lymphomas
to date there have been no immune
checkpoint inhibitors that have received
approval for leukemia
however we do appreciate the critical
role that
diesel activity plays in the control of
aml
after it was observed over 40 years ago
that the graft versus leukemia effect
associated with allogeneic stem cell
transplant was effective at eliminating
leukemic disease
so just a tiny background on immune
checkpoint therapy using monoclonal
antibodies
so there are a variety of co-stimulatory
and co-inhibitory molecules
that tightly regulate the response of
t-cell
to both antigen
presenting and infected cells and so
this cohort upon activation and
stimulation through the
mhc and t cell receptor requires both
co-stimulation through cd28
um and also the
most prevalent uh inhibitory molecules
include the program death uh protein one
as well as ttla4 for this talk we'll be
discussing the interaction
of pd-1 and its cognitive ligands pdl1
and pdl2
so uh there are now multiple um
monoclonal antibodies in trial for
blocking either pd-1
pdl-1 or pdl2 and
the mechanism is such that blocking the
in the interaction between the pd-1 and
the pdl-1 expressed on the tumor cells
uh removes the inhibitory blockade and
allows the t-cell to go about
its effector function of destroying
the tumor cell
so there are multiple clinical trials
now introducing icis
into the aml setting
most of which are in combination with
hypomethylating agents
and this is actually motivated by some
research done at m
anderson in 2014 where it was shown
that hypomethylating agents could
actually increase the expression of pdl1
pdl2 and pd1 in a variety of myeloid
malignancies
and the data here actually demonstrates
that
over the course of treatment it was
patients that were resistant to
hypomethylating agents
had higher expression of both pdl1 and
pdl2
it was also demonstrated that the pd-1
pdl1 signaling access
has profound anti-leukemic response so
in a pdx
model of acute myeloid leukemia they
found
that treatment with an anti-pdl1
antibody
significantly improved overall survival
of these mice
and lastly there have now um they have
now achieved
uh durable clinical clinical responses
in a hypomethylating agent pd-1
inhibitor trial
in acute myeloid leukemia
so the goal of our study was to
use uh serial serially collected patient
samples from refractory relapse aml
patients undergoing therapy within and
with a hypomethylene
hypomethylating agent asocytosine uh
in combination with the pdl-1 inhibitor
a value map
for the treatment um as i mentioned
refractory relapse anal patient samples
but the goal was really with this study
to use these
samples and look at the single cell
protein level to better understand the
immune landscape
of refractory relapse leukemias as well
as identify
potential mechanisms of resistance in
this setting
so the clinical trials designed as such
it's a 28-day
cycle where patients received the
hypomethylating agent azocytosine
for seven consecutive days um in
addition to
two treatments of the antipedial one
antibody on days one and day 14.
for our study we collected both
peripheral blood and bone marrow at
baseline
as well as serial measurements at the
ends of cycles one
three and five and after all of this
processing
we were able to generate data serial
serially collected data for nine of
these patients
so in designing our cytops panel what we
were really interested in looking at
is both the immune
cells adjacent to our leukemias and so
we included uh phenotypic markers for
both aml
as well as a more extensive
t-cell phenotyping panel we also
included
certain markers for other known effector
immune cells in the bone marrow and
peripheral blood including
monocytes and k cells and b cells
um and then we filled the remaining
channels
actually with a variety of immune
checkpoints that we would have
hypothesized be expressed on either the
t
cells or the adjacent aml
cells
and since this is a very cytop oriented
crowd i thought i would give just a
little
more specifics on how we um chose to run
these cytotox samples
so all of the cytoplasm samples were
collected as part of the clinical trial
and frozen
between 2017 and 2018 and so when we
went back to evaluate these samples we
chose to
um take all samples from a given patient
uh and run them in a barcoded cypher
batch
in order to control variability from
batch to batch
we also use a pooled set of healthy
pbmcs that we run
with each as an internal standard
and we use the same
uh antibody master mix for all of these
so to reduce any variability in the
master mix preparation
um and then lastly we do all of our data
preprocessing
which includes the removal of debris and
dead cells
and doublets using flojo
and then we perform umap analysis
with phenograph using cytoskit in our
studio
so using one of our aml patient samples
i'd like
just like to walk you through an example
of how we went about analyzing this data
and so here what you can see is one aml
patient sample
um at baseline uh from bone marrow
and you see a very nice separation
between the cd3
um both the cd4 positive t cells and cd8
positive t cells here at the bottom
um that separates from this large mass
of uh acute myelin leukemia cells
and we actually detect acute myeloid
leukemia a cd45 dim
and they also express markers of
immature myeloid cells including cd34
on the left and cd 38 on the right and
what you'll notice here
is that we identify a more stem-like
leukemia in those that are cd34-positive
cd38-negative
in this cluster here to the left
so our original hypothesis was that
these aml patient samples at baseline
would express
high abundance of pdl1 on the blast
cells and that these would either be
selectively eliminated over the course
of treatment
however what we saw on the majority of
our patient samples upon first
inspection
was that at baseline we saw very little
pdl1
on the tumor cells and so then we next
hypothesized that maybe after
a first cycle where they had been
exposed to the hypomethylating agent we
would see an increase
um maybe of the pdl1 in that context
however
as you walk through the same umap
projection of this
patient sample throughout course of
treatment what you'll see is
that pdl1 expression does not change
significantly
after one cycle of treatment or after
three cycles of treatment
and even after five cycles of treatment
and in fact
we saw no selective uh inhibition or
regulation of pdl-1
in this context so because we ran
our experiment with a number of other
checkpoints we were able to go back
and specifically look at the aml blasts
from a variety of patients
so in this particular heat map we're
looking at the fraction of aml
cells or the percentage of aml cells
that express
a certain um immune ligand across eight
different samples for which we have
serial measurements here
and what we were surprised to see is
that across the board
we saw very little pdl1 expression
in these refractory relapsed aml samples
however
we were surprised to find that its
paired ligand which is pdl2
appears to have high expression across
the board
and across disease progression so
we looked both at the peripheral blood
and baseline of
uh for six of these for which we had
both peripheral blood and bone marrow
measurements
and what we found was that the pdl2 was
actually significantly higher
both when looking at the aml in the
peripheral blood as well as when looking
at
the aml resident and the bone marrow
and so we went back to the data and we
looked through these patient samples to
see um pdl2 expression over the course
of treatment
so again here you see in our more
stem-like population we have the highest
expression of our pdl2
and as we watch this patient progress
patient progress over treatment
we see that the pdl2 is upregulated
after cycle 1 persists even through
cycle 3 when the patient
blast count is lower and you'll notice
here a small population that's beginning
to emerge
that is present when the patient is
removed from trial
due to non-response and again um
we see that the pdl2 expression is
highest at this point
and is also present on a newly emerging
clone
of leukemia
so in a similar uh similar kind of heat
map
we can look at not just the baseline
expression or the baseline abundance of
these other immune checkpoints but what
we see is actually uh
here the numbers in the um heat map
represent
the percentage of blast positive at
baseline
and then we've color coded this to say
whether or not
a patient in each column
has increased by greater than five
percent
uh stable or decreased by more than five
percent
the um abundance of glass with these
particular immune checkpoints
and so what you can appreciate is that
in most of the patients
we see that the majority of these other
immune checkpoints are either stable or
increasing over the course of treatment
and so the summary for this first part
of the data is that
um cdl2 is actually our most abundantly
expressed immune checkpoint that we
interrogated
and this may help to explain some of the
discrepancy we see in the clinic in
response to pd-1 inhibitors versus pdl-1
inhibitors
this also gives us uh the increased
expression of some of these other immune
checkpoints including tidget
ox40 and tim3 um gives us a real
appreciation to the complexity
of of um immune control in the myeloid
setting
and this is something that we are
considering for future immunotherapy
trials
so the other thing that we were able to
do with this data is actually look
specifically at the t cell compartments
and for this i'm using a different
patient sample
but what we saw and what tended to be
the trend is that
in these refractory relapsed aml patient
samples
um when looking between peripheral blood
and bone marrow at baseline
the majority of patients have
significantly more t cells in the
peripheral blood
than when compared to the bone marrow
which is something that we've seen
in other leukemia settings but what was
interesting is that
in most of the patient samples we could
actually see an influx of t
cells after one course of treatment with
the hypomethylating agent and pdl-1
whether it's due to the monoclonal
antibody or the hypomethylated agent is
unclear but it's something that we
would like to consider going forward
so we took the t cell numbers and ratios
and looked for anything that could be a
possible predictor of response
to the pdl one um
trials and sorry about the strange thing
there
but what we found was that um of this of
the number of patients
um so of the eight patients that we were
able to interrogate
um in this manner we saw that those that
progressed
had significantly more or had a
significantly higher cd4 to cba ratio
when compared to patients that had
stable or disease reduction
as in response to treatment and we could
summarize this another way
by looking at actual changes in blast
count
from cycle to cycle so what you see on
the right
is um the cd4 to cd8 ratio so if it's
if there were more cd8 t cells it will
be positive here on the right if there
were more
or sorry there are more cd8 positive t
cells it will be here to the left of
zero
whereas if there were more cd4 helper t
cells
um the t cell ratio would be above zero
and so um we compared this
to the relative change in the blast
percentage as
uh as clinically defined and we found a
very strong correlation between these
two
markers indicating that response to
this hma plus pdl1 inhibitor
requires that you have an abundance of
cd8 effector t cells
another thing that we were able to look
at with this data and with our
immunophenotyping of the t cells
was actually t cell composition of
refractory relapsed aml which has not
largely been investigated so here what
we're looking at
are three normal bone marrows run with
the same cytokine
along with our 9 aml bone marrows for
which we have baseline measurements
and what we see here is that both the
cd4 and cd8 composition are
significantly different in refractory
relapse leukemia
when compared to the normal bone marrow
and notably
we saw very very few terminally
differentiated and naive t cells
in the aml bone marrows when compared to
the normal bone marrows
we could also look at this t cell
composition over time
so again this is one aml patient sample
that we tracked from bone mu
from bone marrow at baseline to c1 to c3
to c5
and what we found interestingly in both
the cd4 and cd8t cells
was the elimination
of the terminally differentiated as well
as
in the cd4 case the naive t cells over
the course of treatment
again whether this is due to the
hypomethylating agent or the antipedial
one is unclear
but it's something that warrants further
investigation
in the second sample we see a similar
trend
with the reduction of naive and
terminally differentiated cells
and the expansion of effector memory t
cells
so the summary of this second portion of
this data
is that um using this same
uh clinical trial data set we were able
to
um make a few claims about the t cells
of patients with refractory relapsed aml
um and determined that cd4 to cd8 ratio
was the most important predictor that we
had
a response to the hma plus pdl1
inhibition
and we also found that these refractory
relapse samples have significantly more
memory t cells and far fewer naive and
terminally differentiated cd4 and cd8 t
cells
both pre-treatment and over the course
of treatment when compared to healthy
controls
again whether these are specific to
refractory relapse when
when compared to de novo aml or when
compared to
age matched is again under
investigation but worth considering um
as we continue to expand these
immunotherapy trials
into aml and so with that i would just
like to thank
the kona play the lab which helped
considerably in the collection and
processing of all of these clinical
trial samples
the md anderson leukemia department um
this trial was headed by nabil daver
as well as our md anderson flocor and
especially duncan and angelique who are
our scitak gurus and who run all of
these
um for us so
with that i will take any questions
all right
thank you dr herbridge for that
informative presentation
and unfortunately dr herbridge could not
join us for the live
q a submitted any of the questions
submitted today
will be provided offline so go ahead and
submit those and she will be sure to
answer them
but we do want to thank her for her time
today and her important research
i now present our next speaker dr carrie
davis
an assistant professor of pediatrics at
the stanford child
health research institute presenting on
the topic of
understanding cd19 negative relapse
following car t therapies in acute
lymphoblastic leukemia
for complete biography on dr davis
please visit the biography tab at the
top of the screen
dr davis welcome you may now begin your
presentation
good morning everyone thank you so much
for the opportunity
to present uh an ongoing project in our
lab
and happy to be discussing it with you
today uh
we're gonna talk today about uh our work
using
uh mass cytometry to help understand
cd19 negative relapse
uh in patients who suffer these relapses
following
car t immunotherapies for achieved
lymphoblastic leukemia
and i want to right away give attention
to the fact that this work has all been
led by a fantastic postdoc in the group
pablo domizi
and give him credit where credit is due
so uh one note historically
is that a hundred years ago childhood
leukemia
was universally fatal this is a
case report from a a doctor
in birmingham who reported
a few children who presented with large
organs
and high white blood cell counts and and
you know
invariably uh succumb to their disease
within only a couple of
months but uh
b-cell childhood leukemia which is the
most common type of cancer in children
is really a poster child for success in
cancer treatment
these kaplan-meier occurs i'm showing
you are from the studies consecutively
at st
dude children research hospital which
really shows the progress from the 1960s
in which less than
uh you know 10 percent of children
survived
uh up until now actually even a decade
ago
where for many children we can quote
survival and long-term survival over 90
percent
however one of the main challenges that
we still face with these patients
is relapse leukemia and about 15 to 20
percent of children
still relapse and even though we have
had this fantastic new option for these
patients which is
uh car t cells which are
t cells that are engineered to recognize
a protein on leukemia cells
we still have a significant amount of
patients that fail these therapies
this kaplan-meier curve is from the
sort of pivotal trial of tysogen leclue
cell which is the
novartis cd19 card t cell and this is
what led to the approval
uh by the fda for this first car t cell
therapy
and we participated in this study at
stanford and
you know one of the things that was as
fantastic as it is in getting patients
into remission
you can see in the black curve which is
event free survival
um that almost half of patients did have
an event
um and and uh most of these were
relapses and the majority of which were
patients who relapsed in which their
leukemia no longer expressed
the car t cell target of cd19 so a cd19
negative relapse so in this project
we really wanted to focus on failure
with car t
cells and try to understand who will
have cd19 negative relapses
and if we can understand uh at the time
that the patient receives the car t
cells uh are there cells within that
you know mixture of billions of cells um
that
are more likely to become cd19 negative
and and mediate or relapse and this is
really in line
with what we try to do in my lab which
is using uh
mass cytometry as a way to look at
uh primary patient samples and
understand
uh cell populations that are associated
with clinical endpoints
so we already know a bit about cd19
negative relapse in the face of
uh targeted therapy both uh car t cells
and
linotomimab which is another uh
bi-specific antibody
or a byte antibody actually that that
targets cd19 positive cells
so there's been description of frame
shift mutations in the cd19
extracellular domain that then makes it
difficult for the
t cell to recognize cd19 there's been
description of trans differentiation
of cells to a myeloid lineage um so that
with pressure on cd19 the cells
altogether can switch
um to looking more myeloid there's been
reports of disruption of cd19
trafficking to the membrane such that
the the protein gets
stuck intracellularly and this actually
can be mediated through
also a chaperone protein for cd19 which
is
cd81 and then there's also been a
description of uh
intracellular isoforms or splice
isoforms
of cd19 that again either
makes the protein not express the part
of the
of the protein that is recognized by the
car t cell or potentially
that involves
again localization within the cell and
this has been described in
two different papers also with intron
retention
so from our standpoint we wanted to look
at the pre-car t-cell sample and we have
two hypotheses
to try to explain cd19 negative relapse
one that we call immune pressure
adaptation
meaning that you have a uniformly cd19
positive cell population going into car
t
cells under the pressure of the car you
end up with
cd19 negative cells uh through some
mechanism
versus um a contrary hypothesis which is
an immune pressure enrichment meaning
that
within the majority of the cells that
seem to express
cd19 before you give the car t cell that
there is hiding within there some cd19
negative cells
that then those are the cells that can
escape the pressure of the car t cell
and grow out to recapitulate the
leukemia
we started by taking some of the rna
sequencing data
that was in elena satea's cancer
discovery paper which
um they had the where they described the
splice isoforms
and we just looked at immunoglobulin
rearrangements
um within that data and here i'm showing
you
a two patient examples both looking at
heavy chain
on the top row and light chain
rearrangements in those two patients
and we could see that there were shared
sequences
both in the heavy and light chains in
the pre-car sample and in the post car
sample at the relapse and suggesting
that there was
um you know share some clones that were
there
at the beginning before the patient had
even seen uh
the pressure of the car and persisted to
the relapse
collaborating then with david barrett
and steve grupp
at children's hospital of philadelphia
and university of pennsylvania
we were able to take a look at initially
at four
paired samples from patients who had
gotten
cd19 car for relapsed alo these were all
expanded in a mouse so they're actually
all xenograss derived samples
and just by using our sort of our
standard
allo panel with the scitock we looked at
42 markers
and just doing an initial sort of high
level look at
the phenotype of these samples we could
see that they actually segregated based
on
their um genetic uh or or
mechanism of cd19 loss from what we knew
of the samples
such that a healthy bone marrow that was
analyzed with them
completely separates away from the rest
of the leukemia samples and we see that
uh chop one which is the patient that
has had the cd19 positive or sorry 19
splice isoforms both in the pre-car
and post-car sample separates
phenotypically away from the three other
patients that were known to have
mutations in the cd19 gene
one of the tools that we use in our lab
to look at leukemia samples is
a developmental classifier in which we
uh classify leukemia cells
based on their uh most similar b cell
population in the bone marrow
and one of uh when we applied our
classifier to this data now to sort of
segregate these cells
into subpopulations interestingly what
we found
was that at the time of cd19 loss at the
relapse which is shown in red
there was this significant enrichment in
cells that classified as
early non-b1 cells in our classification
so we were really lucky then to be able
to expand
our cohort of patient samples to try to
see if this was something that was
you know specific to this small pilot
set or if we
saw a similar pattern when we looked at
additional samples and again
um all of this is through collaboration
with uh david
and steve at the university of
pennsylvania
and here then we were able to look at
patients who had complete remission
after their car patients who suffered a
cd19 negative relapse and for those
patients we had
eight pairs post car relapse samples
we had a smaller group of patients who
suffered a cd19 positive relapse and for
those we had two
post relapse samples and then finally we
had five patients who received
a 19 directed card but never had any
response and so were termed refractory
and for these we had also some paired
samples
so just looking at cd19 alone
we noted that there was no difference
either in the percent of cd19 positive
cells
especially in the pre-car sample between
these um
four groups of patients um and then
if we look actually at the median level
of cd19 in the cells
there was no difference between these
groups aside from the patients who went
on
to suffer a 19 negative relapse
after their car which there was
obviously a statistically significant
difference in both the
number of or the percentage of 19
positive cells and the level of 19 on
the cells
but then when we did our developmental
classification in these different groups
we found that in the patients who went
on to a complete remission
that they tended to have a um a very
typical expansion in what we call pro-v2
cells
compared to the other groups and here
i'm highlighting
patients who went on to complete
remission versus those that had a 19
positive relapse
here's what it looks like for patients
who had a complete remission
versus those who had a 19 negative
relapse and here's what it looks like
for patients who
had a complete remission versus who were
refractory
so in each case where patients either
were refractory or suffered a relapse
um there were less cells in this pro-b2
population
although this only reached statistical
significance on when comparing
to the refractory patients
when we went and looked specifically now
at the patients who had a 19 negative
relapse and looked at the paired samples
now
with more patients again we saw this
enrichment
in the early non-v cell population which
was again
significant compared to the pre-car
sample
and just to drill down into how our
developmental classifier works
um we use this by
taking healthy bone marrow controls that
we always include in our experiments
and the healthy bone marrows are gated
based on
what we know is the progression of these
cell developments and then
each healthy population is is assigned a
developmental bar code
of 11 different proteins in this case
though we always use cd19 because cd19
is a
a known important marker of of b cell
miss
but in this case we asked the question
about whether or not in
what was happening when these cells
don't have cd19
so we asked what would happen if we
excluded cd19 from the classifier
but used the remaining markers and this
i'm showing here is
healthy bone marrow our healthy bone
marrow controls and when we actually
include
um on in the blue on the left uh cd19 in
the classifier you can see that there's
you know perfect agreement um of where
cells are classified
versus if we exclude it again there's
very little impact on where cells
are are classified whether or not 19 is
is there or not
in our classification but this was not
the case with the leukemia cells and in
fact
what we ended up seeing was that
in the leukemia samples without
cd19 we found these cells that we call
pro-b2 discordant cells
and so what that means is that when we
include cd19 in the classification these
cells are called pro-v2 cells
but when we exclude it from the
classification they end up being called
early non-v1 cells which sort of
explains why we saw this
enrichment in that population in the
cd19 negative relapse
samples however within these patient
samples as well there were some cells
that with or without 19 maintained their
classification
as pro b2 cells so really there was a
a subset of these cells that
you know changed sort of what they
looked like whether or not we used
19 to define them
we actually went to a another data set
that we had in the lab which is
de novo all so these are patients who
are newly diagnosed and have never had
car t
cells and we asked the same question
about you know can we find
these discordant pro-b2 cells by
classifying these patient cells with or
without um
cd19 in the classifier and out of our 22
samples we had
17 of them that had more than 100 cells
classified as pro v2
and here this bar graph is showing you
the percentage of those
um pro b2 cells that would be considered
discordant
if we excluded cd19 from the classifier
so this told us that
these discordant pro b2 cells are not
just specific
in some way to patients who are
receiving car t cells or even
necessarily to relapse the all but they
appear to exist in both conditions
and here i can show you a summary of the
frequency of 42
cells within all of our groups so they
certainly were present
in patients who went into complete
remission with carr
they were present in patients who had a
19 negative relapse
as well as refractory or 19 positive
patients
and de novo aol as well but we did not
see them in healthy bone marrow
so when we started to compare on the
protein level uh the differences
in the proteins that are expressed
between all of the different
combinations here so
probi2 versus early non-b cells
probitude discordant versus pro-b2 cells
and then pro-v2 discordant versus early
non-b cells
we could see quite a lot of proteins
that were
differentially expressed and these
included
a lot of interesting players i think in
florida's b-cell identity including
pac-5 and icaros
and p1 so transcription factors that
help regulate
cell identity as well as other
car targets such as cd 22
or for example cd20 which is not a
widely used car target but there are
things
in development to target cd20 as well as
other monoclonal antibody agents
when we started to drill down a little
bit more into then you know doing what
we love to do with the scitop which is
to be able to look at multiple
um features within these individual
cells or in these individual populations
we found that in the patients who are
going to have a 19 negative relapse that
these pro-v2 discordant cells
do have some unique features in
comparison here to patients who go on to
have a complete remission
so for example as i had previously shown
you and you would expect
the discordant pro v2 cells have
really a very um
slight difference in cd19 in the pre-car
sample however they do have differences
in in pack five in foster nf kappa b
and in icarus and and that the patients
who go on to have a 19 negative relapse
have lower levels of these
proteins in their pre-car sample in the
probe two discordant cells and when you
start to look at them combinatorially
um there's differences in between these
cells where the
the patients that go on to a negative
relapse will have lower levels of pac-5
and it grows
in the pre-car sample and this is
provocative in the standpoint that
cd19 is a known target of pax 5 so
it makes me wonder about whether or not
these are cells that are somewhat poised
um
to already suffer 19 negative relapse
because they're
wired differently to enable
either 19 to to turn off under pressure
we wanted to understand a little bit
also if there was
um a cd19 negative um early non-b
cell in healthy bone marrow since this
was what
defines these early non-b cell
populations um that we were seeing with
the classifier
so pablo took a look at four different
healthy bone marrows ran the classifier
and took the cells that were identified
as early non-d cells
and performed an unsupervised clustering
and within
that one population that through
classification we call early non-b cells
we found three clusters if we looked at
these three clusters we could see
um that within them they were 19
negative
but there was here shown in blue cluster
three a population there within the four
marrows that expressed
immunoglobulin heavy chain or igm on the
surface and had hladr
um suggesting that this could be you
know sort of a cognate population and
healthy bone marrow
that could lead to cd19 negative relapse
in these patients with leukemia
so in order to fall follow all this
one of the things that we've now started
to look at is
looking more closely at these samples um
using
sequence-based cytometry with a whole
transcript and analysis
in our pro-b2 discordant cells
um well in actually all of these
leukemia cells
and using uh this is using abseq
to be able to identify both our um ob2
cells
our early 90 cells but also then look at
the whole transcriptome within these
cells
so what we did is we did uh a total of
nine
samples so three patients who uh before
i got their car
and who ended up having a group response
three patients who ended up having a
negative relapse
and then we have those paired from
before and after so
car and post the negative relay and as
well we have a healthy bone marrow
that's been included on all of these
cartridges
so similarly to what we've done
previously with
cytosol data by projecting all cells
into healthy bone marrow stays in the
protein levels
we're starting to be doing here on the
trip dome level um so here's a umass
showing you on the left-hand side what
the healthy brow controls
like through uh through a new map
visualization
we get 17 different clusters in the
healthy marrow space
whereas on the right side is where
hemias
cluster into this piece and we found
that primarily
they occupied cluster 6 cluster 14
cluster 7 and cluster 9
and i'll show you this a little more
concisely on the next slide
but um in particular looking at being
expression
um cluster 6 eb are coordinate cells
and and i will give you a little bit of
an idea of why i'm coming from
whereas cluster 14 and cluster seven
look like they are
our you know very early uh pro-b cells
western freebie cells based on their
gene expression
so here's the same sort of a line graph
that showed you with the development
classifier with these samples
so in this case now the cluster id is on
the x-axis so it doesn't necessarily
correlate with
a developmental uh stage uh
across the but as i mentioned in
all these samples including the patients
who go on most of the cells sit
in cluster six or cluster 14 and you can
see within the patient
on the top row have a pre and post
carcinogens
there are some some swap in frequency
that happen between a pre and car sample
but for the most part they still
occupy the two specific clusters
so looking a little bit more deeply in
cluster six um
we are asking questions are these
potentially what we had previously
identified
as this coordinate probisa um pablo took
the top 100 cells
um from uh from these all the machines
that we look at
and did uh some differential analysis
through the gene aggression and you can
see that there are
both uh up-regulated and down-regulated
uh
sets of genes that separate these two
chemical statuses
some of them include things we would
have expected such as
tt as well as a way genes that regulate
hla
and relate the endogenous chain which i
have here highlighted
in red
so this all ongoing work so to be
continued to stay tuned as we continue
to you know get in analyzing
um this additional single data and and
and overlaying it with iphone
that we had uh we're really um excited
about
uh integrating these two data types and
uh use them to inform
each other and go back to potentially
look at patient samples
so i apologize that this is cut off on
the topic uh to summarize
uh our proposed models you know where is
the source of these cd88 resistance
cells
what we've made happening is that um
this
immune pressurization where there could
be cells in what
they are feeding they are all cd19
positive or appear to be
pressure of car but in fact if there are
these cells that
uh are pretty deported cells that
initially express 19 but are more prone
to losing 19 uh under pressure
and so there actually may be sort of a
merger of these two model where
um you may have both things happening at
the time and so with that
uh i'm gonna wrap up i'm gonna say uh uh
thank you to all the people who've been
involved in this but of course like i
mentioned
uh the work has been led by uh pablo
domiti uh
and then of course in collaboration with
dave baer and steve gruff at university
of pennsylvania
um with support and samples from charles
mulligan and lots of input from
crystal makel uh primarily supported by
the z foundation financially
so thank you so much for the opportunity
to to talk with you about this and i'm
happy to take questions
thank you dr davis for that informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please just click on that ask a
question box located on the far
left of your screen so it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in
dr davis have you applied the same
analysis
to patients um receiving the targeted
therapies
in violence mod or cd22
cars
oops it looks like we cannot hear you
you might have muted yourself on that
end
if you go to the bottom of the screen
where
um we can see each other um right where
there's that little microphone if you
click on it
it can it can you can turn it to the
correct microphone maybe you
accidentally switched it to
the wrong one
or if it's
is it red maybe has a line through it
and you want to unmute
uh oh
if you want to if it still doesn't work
you can quickly jump out and then come
back in
that could work as well and i want to
thank our audience members we do have
some great questions coming in
we want to encourage you to continue to
add those
questions this is a great
great workshop and we want everyone to
participate
so we'll just give these technical
problems happen on occasion
we all know don't worry
you can either click on that source at
the bottom
of the picture it looks like she's going
to log out and log right back in
and again thank you so much for all of
your patience
i'm sure everyone has dealt with these
kind of technological
issues especially throughout this
pandemic so thank you
um
okay can you hear me now susie we can
hey um
sorry about that thank you to our
audience members
and i do want to just that encourage
people to
join in at the fluid dime booths in the
exhibit hall
too this has been a great um opportunity
and flu dime has been
awesome in this whole experience so
thank them
um so kara let's go back to these great
questions and
and we already have some coming in and i
know we'll get some more
our first questions were was have you
applied that same analysis
to patients receiving other targeted
therapies
like the final two and i apologize for
not saying it right
biotinumab mod or 22 cars
yeah that's a that's a mouthful that
that drive yeah
um anyway i wanted to say thank you
susie thanks for having me to
to the organizers here and uh good good
morning or good afternoon to everyone
uh joining us today so
we have not directly applied these same
analyses to patients
receiving blended tumor blenditum is the
bi-specific or bite antibody that also
targets cd19
and is uh has been really another
exciting
new agent for leukemia um
so we're but we are very enthusiastic
and are working actually collaboratively
to try to
to obtain some patient samples from
patients who've received
glennatumamab we have actually though
really been excited to been able to take
a look at some
paired samples from patients who
received a car
targeting cd22 which is an alternative
target in all and other b sound
malignancies like lymphoma
so we have a collaboration with narali
shaw
at the national cancer institute who had
the first clinical trial for cv22
in in the u.s and then we also now
actually run
a cd 22
a cd22 trial at stanford uh and uh
and we're all so we've taken a look at
some of those samples as well that data
analysis is certainly a little bit
more immature um but we're certainly
looking
uh to uh to to integrate some of the
observations we're making with the cd19
uh along with the cd22 samples because
we actually also have
observed clinically that after cd 22
targeted car it's it is very common for
patients to
drop the level of cd22 when they relapse
uh so it's it's an antigen that almost
seems like it is even more
um susceptible to pressure
so stay tuned thank you so much
and are these types of studies being
used in investigating other types of
blood
neoplasms with other therapies
i mean absolutely i think uh i know in
in my group we have
multiple projects going on looking at
both aml and all with other
other therapies or other sort of
emerging therapies
we've looked at already have looked at
bcl2 inhibitors which is a really
exciting drug that's being applied both
in all
and aml and of course we heard
in the previous presentation from
shelley about
you know looking at these leukemias in
response to checkpoint inhibition
and then the advantage there also being
able to look at the immune system from
the same patient samples which
you know really is advantageous when
you're trying to do this sort of
translational work where you have
potentially limited cell numbers from
primary patient samples and and being
able to leverage
looking at many different cell
populations from one precious sample
thank you so much now one of our
audience members want to know
can you speak to the advantages of using
mass otometry
and ab seek in your research
um so so that is uh something i'm pretty
excited about uh
in in the sense that we oftentimes you
know have
identified these um cell populations of
interest using
mass cytometry and then to have the
opportunity to
um sort of use that to inform
what cell populations we want to go
after and and
even get more information on them i
think uh we're all
sort of hungry for parameters and
uh of course with with the scitov we can
do amazing things
uh but then of course doing sort of
unsupervised transcriptomic analysis
uh we get even more parameters and i'm
really excited about the opportunity to
start to merge and overlay these data
types
um so that we can get even more precise
understanding of the cell populations um
because one of the things that sort of
continually amazes me with doing this
work is the
incredible diversity of cells that we
have
in our bone marrow which is primarily
where we're working but of course this
probably applies to all of our body and
and so being able to understand those
different cell types and their
sort of propensities will help us
hopefully learn how to treat patients
better
you know down the road thank you so much
now
is there any utilization in the near
future
for these therapies and non-cancer
diseases with
like let's say an immune dysfunction an
example
liver pathologies yeah so
uh car t cells are actually being used
for
um infection as well and particularly
viral infections
following a solid organ transplant for
example or bone marrow transplant
and so there also certainly is
opportunity just to understand
and potentially target cell populations
that are
a problem um when when in
either rheumatologic diseases or
autoimmune diseases
uh so i think there is an opportunity
for
uh first for using them both that i mean
there's already ongoing work but again
further
uh you know further expansion of this
work into other areas
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
are these types of studies being used in
investigating
other types of blood neoplasms
disease in general
yeah so i think that
exactly that there are opportunities
also to
look at solid tumors or you know solid
tissues we'll put it that way both from
the standpoint of looking at
immune infiltrate but also looking at
the tumor tissue themselves
there's already been some some published
work uh
doing uh tissue dissociation to be able
to take
solid tumors and look at individual
cells which is of course the one of the
you know the real power
uh of these technologies of scitov so
i think you know those things are are
coming and there's uh you know protocols
and
and uh experimental approaches to
address
uh you know and be able to expand the
the reach
of the technology thank you so much
now do you potentially see a role for
using
mastotometry for assessing minimal
residue residual disease um
in general yeah so great question
we actually have a whole another project
working on that
um led by another postdoc in the lab and
um i'm not sure that i see that a cytoph
in every
clinical lab but certainly um
we are learning that uh you know you can
if you
if you assay a lot of different proteins
and look at a lot of different markers
you can potentially identify the best
set of markers
uh to to look at for example a minimal
residual disease
and so you know i think that there
absolutely is a role we know that both
with the
uh ability to look at so many proteins
and sort of the analysis techniques
that we are really nicely able to find
abnormal cells which for us clinically
helps us guide treatment decisions
dr davis thank you so much would you
like to provide
any additional remarks before we move to
our next
speaker sure i think i want to say again
thanks for the the opportunity
to be here with you all this morning and
to talk about our work
uh and uh certainly i'm very interested
to to stay on and listen
uh to my colleague dr bowden miller
who's following
uh uh in his very uh relevant work to
to our unusual times but thanks everyone
for being here with us today
and thank you again dr davis and thank
you for your time and for your important
research
i now want to move to our last and
wonderful speaker
dr byrne bodenmiller professor of
quantitative biology
at the department of quantitative
biomedicine at the university of
zurich presenting on the topic of mass
cytometry
reveals distinct immune signature
marking progression from mild to severe
covid19 for complete biography of dr
bowden miller
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr gordon miller welcome you may now
begin your presentation
sir
thanks for the nice introduction and
also i would like to thank
the organizers of the meeting for giving
me the opportunity
to talk about our recent work on the
immunoprofiling of peripheral blood
of mild and severe comet 19
patients as you all know
we have currently an ongoing worldwide
pandemic
caused by the south kofta virus
over 29 million people already have been
infected with this virus and nearly 1
million people
have died of it here you see a world map
that shows
which countries have been mainly
affected
and in europe we are through the first
wave but in most countries
there's already again the ramp up of
cases in some countries like france
actually steeply
and also in spain where we already are
in the midst
of a second wave
in um covet 19 patients
can be asymptomatic many have only
mild symptoms but some of them show
severe symptoms and about five percent
uh are ultimately critical cases
and overall we have a fairly high
mortality in this disease which is
estimated
to be between 0.5 to 1
of all cases and we aimed
to generate high dimensional single cell
proteomic data
to help us understand the key
differences between
the mild and the severe disease to
ultimately identify early on patients at
risk
and of course also to help understand
the underlying biology of the disease
and to address this we performed mass
cytometry and targeted proteomic
measurements to characterize a cohort of
mild
and severe covet 19 patients
and those samples were collected in four
different hospitals in zurich
switzerland
as a side note the results of our work
is described in two manuscripts
that you can find on bioarchives under
those two links
one focusing on the innate compartment
and the second one focusing on t cells
in the presentation today i will show
you parts
of both of these manuscripts
and analyses
in this data set that i will show you
today
66 covet patients are included
these were sampled at different time
points after symptom onset
to the left you see number of patients
x-axis is the time
of the symptom onset and you can also
see in a color code
a code whether those patients had mild
disease
or a severe disease or even acute
respite
so respiratory distress syndrome
um as it's known for covet 19 among the
severe cases
men are actually over represented
he also found as others a strong
relationship
with age for the disease severity that
is shown here to the right by the most
severe cases
among the oldest patients of the cohort
also if you look at the hospitalization
we see a strong relationship to the age
of the patients
and also when we look more finely
grained at the different
disease features we again see as
expected
a strong relationship to the age of
these patients
we then took all of these patient
samples
and in addition had 22 healthy donors
and we analyzed the pbmcs
using an antibody panel for the innate
cells as well as
for the adaptive immune cells and each
panel had
contained 40 antibodies and we analyzed
all of those
cells then by mass cytometry and overall
required about
6 million cells in two batches using a
60 well
barcoding scheme in parallel
we used the serum of all of these
patients
and we did cytokine profiling using the
so-called
o-link approach in the first step
then we identified the main immune cell
subsets
using a random forest classifier to the
upper left you can see a tc map that
shows the different main
uh immune cell phenotypes including
cdi84 t cells
e cells plasma cell centric cells
monocytes
anky cells vascular fuels neutrophils
etc
to the lower left you see a heat map
then the x-axis you see the different
markers that we analyzed on the y-axis
the different phenotypes and the
expression of the markers from to lowest
to red highest level we then plotted
the cell type frequencies which are
shown to the left
versus the disease severity
and here we found and this others
people also found while we actually
analyzed our data
that there's a depletion of cdit cells
among the severe patients but that
there's an
increase of the monocytes also among the
severe patients
and this that led us to analyze in more
depth
the monocytes as well uh as as the
t-cell
well the myeloid compartment and the
t-cells
and when we then look closer at the
myeloid compartment
um i first want to show you this t-sne
map here that is colored by the disease
grade
and in green you see cells derived
from healthy patient samples blue
from patients samples from patients that
had mild disease
and red from patients that had a severe
disease
and please note that there's a region
that is exclusively occupied by cells
from patients with mild and cv disease
now here to the right the t's new map
are colored
by the myeloid specific markers again
from blue lowers to red highest
normalized intensity
and then it was striking to see
that cv 169 showed a very strong
relationship
to the region where we had the cells
derived from samples of patients with
mild
ncb disease and also other markers such
as cb64
in fact showed some relationship to the
dc state
and this clearly showed us that tb 169
was strongly upregulated in the myeloid
compartment
in a subset of kovite 19 patients
we then used phenograph to determine
the main monocyte phenotype clusters
these are shown here on the heat map
again on the x-axis you see the markers
that we measured
the color scale is the median scale
expression from blue lowest
to red highest and this enabled us
to determine the non-classical
and intermediate monocytes that express
cd16
and here expressing cb169
activated monocytes and down here
expressing expressing cd14 but
not expressing cv16
the classical monocytes
in the next step then we wanted uh to
know
how these monocytes these activated
monocytes
where they might have been originated
from so we
analyzed the putatives onto the genic
relationship
between the different monocyte clusters
and to do so
we used a diffusion mapping and the
diffusion mapping
actually showed us that these activated
monocytes could be derived
from this classical monocytes but also
from those uh non-classical monocytes
and in hiv it actually
had already been described that the cd
169 positive monocytes can be
found both on cd16 positive and cd16
are negative monocytes
so clearly can be could be from the
classical and the non-classical
compartment
the next step we wanted to see
which of these monocyte phenotype
clusters
are associated to the dc states
of our cohort for that purpose
we made a stacked histogram plot
where for the different monocyte
clusters at the color scale
is shown here to the right where we plot
the proportion
for every individual patient of the
different mono
site clusters and the x-axis
is showing all of the different samples
now just looking at this stacked
histogram
i think it's very clear that there are
three groups
this is group here to the left where we
mainly have the activated monocytes
now here on the top you can see the
disease
severity and you can also see that
for those patients and samples where we
mainly have this activated monocytes we
typically find
patients that had a mild or and or
or a severe disease then there's a
second group
here in the center where we have many
classical monocytes and these are
associated
mainly with the healthy donors there is
a third group
that is shown here to the right where we
have higher proportions
of a subset for example six classical
monocytes
and these are associated uh with a
severe disease
so then we analyze this more
systematically
using a box block box plots which
represent cluster frequencies
across those patient groups now here on
the top
uh you see the classical monocytes here
to the left the non-classical monocytes
and here to the bottom right you see the
activated monocytes
and you can now see that for these
activated monocytes
you have higher frequency for the
patients with my disease
while for the classical monocytes and
here for the non-classical
monocytes you can see that their
frequencies actually reduced
for the patients with a mild disease
in the next step we then wanted to
analyze
the pseudodynamic of these different
monocyte clusters and here we could
exploit
that we sampled the patients at
different time points
after symptom onset and so here
on the x-axis then you have the time of
the onset
the y-axis at the frequency and
several things and become clear when we
look now at these clusters
of the classical monocytes the first
like this cluster 1 m2 and m3 they're
depleted
already at the early time points of the
onset
of symptoms but over time uh
at least for for the severe and also for
the
mild patients there's a slow recovery
these groups and f4 and m6 they actually
appear to be transient that there's an
increase in the frequency over time
and then also they decrease again over
time
and then for this m7 there was only a
very weak relationship
found over time when we then looked at
this
non-classical monocytes and
the activated monocytes we could also
see here a very strong relationship in
their frequency
with time after symptom onset
so clearly there is an increased
frequency of the non-classical monocytes
um in
this more severe patients that's the red
line you can see how there's a strong
increase
while if you look now at the cd 169
positive deactivated bonus size
you can see that early on
after symptom onset you have a high
frequency
but then that is transient and that then
the frequency
is actually reduced over time
so very often um
very often monocyte development
homeostasis and also the fight i mean
these points are strongly interlinked
with the
cytokine and chemokine environment
so in order to probe the cytokine and
chemokine
environment we use the our link targeted
inflammation assay and so here you have
two antibodies
binding against the cytokine or
chemokine
on the antibody you have a dna tag
then when both antibodies can bind and
they are close enough then you can do a
proximity extension essay
and after the extension you can do a
preamp modification and then you can do
a qpcr to quantify the amount of a
chemokine or cytokine in your sample
and so we then compared which
of those cytokines chemokines are
differentially expressed
comparing the healthy diverse disease
severe causes and you can clearly see
how pro-inflammatory cytokines such as
l6
tnf il-18 or
interferon gamma are actually
significantly
upregulated compared to the healthy
controls
and overall we analyze the 92
inflammation markers
so also here then we performed a pseudo
dynamic
observatory time analysis to look at the
pseudodynamic changes
in the cytokine expression upon simple
onset which again is shown
or plotted on the x-axis the time of the
simple onset
and now the normalized protein
expression
is shown for the different markers that
are shown here
on the y-axis
and one can now clearly see that for
example in the case of interferon gamma
um early on the high levels for the
severe cases
but that it then fades over time when we
look at ccl3
or ccl4 we can see that there's an
increase
of the levels over time for severe
patients
and also mca p2 has a similar behavior
like interferon gamma
in that it's high in the beginning but
then it fails over time
and also other markers showed some
weaker trends mcsf had high levels
initially
and there we saw a slow decrease
for the mild cases
over time we then wanted to see whether
we can
stratify the patients um based on
cellular
and surgical factors for this purpose
then we perform the principal component
analysis
what is plotted here on the x-axis the
first dimension
on the y-axis the second dimension
and it's very clear that we can separate
out
shown in circles healthy cases we can
separate
fairly well the mild cases that are
shown in triangles
and we can also separate using pci
the severe cases that are here in the
region at the bottom
and then we performed by plotting
to find which of the monocyte classes
are associated
with healthy mild ncb disease
and as you already have seen before on
these
large plots that i've shown you the
stacked histograms then
that this classical monocyte classes m1
and 2 and m3 they're associated
with the healthy samples or that up here
this m10 and m12
they're associated with the multi-seas
and that down here the m4 and m6
classical monocytes they're actually
associated
with severe disease
and this really showed us that the
combination of cytokines
and cell clusters define the different
groups
of the patients we then
more systematically analyze the
relationship
between the monocyte clusters and
the chemokines and cytokines and
therefore we perform the correlation
analysis
between in this case the m12 activated
monocyte
cluster and the cytokine levels
and here we saw a strong relationship
between this cluster to mcsf
to mcp2 and also to
interferon gamma and we saw some trends
also for other cytokines
we then also colored the patients
in relation to the time after symptom
onset
and we can see here that those patients
that were analyzed early on
are driving uh this this relationship
and we can also see up here
um that there's an early stage signature
uh that then shows us this association
between the cd169 clusters
12 and that's the cluster we looked at
and mcsf mcp2
and interferon gamma and also we see
a relationship more to the mild cases
than to the severe cases
when we also looked at other clusters
m8 and m9 and these are non-classical
monocytes we did the same analysis
and here we see for cluster 8 a
relationship to ccr3
and ccl4 and here the relationship is
driven
by patients that had a severe disease
and the same is true for cluster 9 and
if we now also
color these plots according to the time
after simple onset
now we can see that it's driven by
a sample that were taken light
after symptom onset and this also said
there's a light stage
signature that identifies an association
between this non-classical cluster
m8 and m9 and ccr3 and
a ccl4
that means that indeed what i stated
initially
we could identify such relationships
and that we could identify signatures
both for early stage
and late stage of the disease and for
mild
and the severe form
so then i just want to show you on a few
slides
some of the analyses we performed on the
t
cell side um and here it was striking to
see
um that um the naive cvid a positive
t cells that when we looked at the
percentage
versus a dc severity that there was a
marked reduction
and also when we looked at the absolute
cell count
we also saw a strong reduction we then
saw
for the central memory one an expansion
when we only looked
at the percentage but we did not really
see that
when we looked at the absolute cell
counts and that really
reveals the importance of assessing
absolute cell counts and not only
looking
at frequencies or percentages
of these different phenotypes
and overall what you could see here is a
pronounced reduction of naive t
cells and overall a t cell lymphopenia
and so we at this point were wondering
what actually accounts for this t
cell lymphopenia for the purpose
we first evaluated whether those cells
become apoptotic
and therefore we made a plot of the c
severity
versus the expression of gleef pulp and
cleaved caspase-3
and indeed we could see an elevation of
those avocado markers
for the among the severe patients
we then also wanted to know and we
hypothesized
whether the t cell lymphopenia could
also be caused
by a tesla migration into inflamed
tissues as another possible mechanism
and so here we looked at the cxcr3
signaling since that is primer
primarily mediating tessa migration
into inflamed lung parenchyma
and indeed what we saw when we looked at
the the levels of cxcr3 a ligands
in the blood cxl9 6l10
611 then we could actually see
a significant increase when we compared
the severe levels to those of the mild
and the healthy samples
and at the same time we saw that there
was a decreased
cxcr3 expression on t cells
in covet expression on t cells and
coincide in patients
and that is also shown down here and
this also indicates that
in addition to apoptosis that t cell
migration
into inflamed lung tissue might drive
the t
cell lymphopenia
so in case there's due to this t-cell
lymphopenia
we hypothesized that there might be
elevated levels
of il-7 so i7 is produced by stroma
cells
typically i7 levels are fairly constant
but if there's a slight increase and
that's something that we could
actually see here when we looked at the
levels of i7
versus dc severity we could see a
trend of an increase of the levels and
especially when we looked at the
time after two symptom onset versus il7
levels
also here we could actually see a trend
um
that there's a systemic il7
elevation
and is-7
is important for t-cell proliferation
and so here then we looked at the levels
of the cdi
positive t cells and
the levels of k-67 which indicates
proliferation
and here now we could see that indeed in
the severe pythons
we had higher levels of k67
and this indicates that r7 might induce
cdit cell proliferation in severely
affected patients and we also saw that
the cdi t cell numbers they increase
with time again when we plot the pseudo
at dynamics versus the cells of the cdit
cells in blood
we could also see here a significant
relationship
or more importantly an increase with
time in those
severe patients
then at this point we actually were
wondering
whether this homeostatic proliferation
is associated to an increase
in poly specific memory t cells that
might be produced
using this i7 induced proliferation
and so we first checked
the uh the t cells um
from the copic 19 patients how well they
were actually responsive
on the level of blast formation between
vitro stimulation
and with different types of viruses and
that is shown here
and i think it's extremely obvious
that the t cells from the patients that
had severe disease
um showed a much lower blast formation
and stimulation
than what you can see in the healthy
controls
and also from patients that only had a
mild form of of the disease
we then made another plot where we
looked
at the net stage stimulation now versus
time
so we again did the pseudo dynamic
analysis
and on the y-axis you see the plot of
the the net stimulation
and here we can actually see an
increased blast formation
for the severe cases upon stimulation
of the virus is shown here as a function
of time and ultimately
what this showed us is that the i7
dependent a t-cell proliferation
isn't using a poly-specific t-cell
expansion
um what i've also shown you is that
t-cell lymphopenia
leads to an emulated il7 levels
at least we see trends that point
towards at this
direction and the underlying mechanism
of the t-cell lymphopenia is likely
avocauses as well as
the migration of the t cells into lung
tissue
and on the inner compartment i hope i
could convince you that we have a clear
innate signature
in kovic 19 patients an earlier response
that is characterized by a surge of c
169 positive monocytes
and interferon gamma and mcp2
and that the severe patients present an
increased amount of pro-inflammatory
monocytes
and elevated levels of ccs3 ccl4
at later time points and with this
i greatly want to acknowledge first my
team
who analyzed those samples and
especially i greatly want to acknowledge
stefan's
chef he really showed off that project
on
our side he did
most of the data analysis and he also
drove
at the writing of this manuscript and i
also want to
greatly acknowledge our collaborators at
university hospital of zurich
first of all honorable boyman and was
extremely
fast intense and very nice productive
collaboration
for the analysis of those patient
samples and also
with jacob nielsen and the members of
of owner's group eve to buchen sarah
adamo
and carlo chavia and i also greatly want
to acknowledge andre jacobs
i did most of the lab work and also
joined in for the data analysis and also
i greatly want to acknowledge
natalie de souza for contributing
with the data analysis and manuscript
writing finally
i want to acknowledge the swiss national
science foundation
who is providing us the financial
resources
to conduct this world look this i'm done
and
i'm happy to receive your questions
thank you dr bowden miller for that
informative presentation we will now
start the q a portion of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
dr voter miller we have quite a few
questions already coming in
we'll see what we can get in in time
today
our first question is what happens
to the cd169 plus monocytes
okay so that's a very good question
because we see that they're coming up
and then they're disappearing again and
this
activated cd 169 monocytes
they could for example end up in the
lung tissue so they express
ccr2 and we also see that in
covet 19 patients ccl2 is upregulated
so they could in the end be recruited
into the lung tissue and then ultimately
also become macrophages it has been
shown in some mouse models
um also of a covet that this is the case
and that's our hypothesis but we of
course only analyzed
um the monocytes in in pbmcs
so we do not know really what what
happens to them and this would require
additional analysis that's in fact also
a bit i would say weakness of our study
that we did not
analyze matched lung tissue
for example thank you so much
our next question comes from an audience
member who actually
asks a two-part question how did you run
these longitudinal samples was it
at all some time point from
one patient at a time with controls like
one full day and then here showing
comparison
and then here showing comparison for
example moderate
or severe our lab is determining the
time of
how we run cytosk samples from these
large cohorts and get at least the
amount of variability due to the running
of different
days i know that's a mouthful but
so that actually is is again a very good
question so the way
we approached it or typically try to do
studies
to reduce uh the variability that
we have in the data due to sample
collection
is that we try to collect the samples
over time
and then perform a single analysis using
a mastec based barcoding and also in
this study um
once the blood samples were taken the
pbmcs
were isolated they were cross-linked in
1.6 percent
pfi and then the sample shaft froze at
minus id
degrees celsius and then after a certain
time point
when we saw it now we likely have enough
samples collected to be able to do
statistical analysis that make sense
then we
barcoded all of the samples i showed
this at the beginning of the talk
and that's how we can avoid a large
variability introduced by sampling over
larger time frames
thank you so much dr brown miller and
again i want to thank our audience
members for these great questions and
any questions not answered today
will be answered via email we have time
for one more question
do we need follow-up bio specimens to
perform such pseudo-time analysis
and if not how do we make assumptions
about
what cell population or cytokines
or chemokines are decreasing or
increasing
over a number of days
so again that's a very good question
and in an ideal experiment
you would sample blood from the same
patient
over the course of of the disease at the
time
when we collected those samples that
unfortunately
was not possible we did however for four
patients
sample blood at two different time
points
and then we could actually confirm all
of the trends that i've shown you in the
pseudo
dynamic of pseudotime analysis and that
gave us confidence that
the assumptions that we make about the
changes over
time are likely correct but i completely
agree we should have
more patience where we do sample
from the same patient blood samples over
the course of the disease
and if you have such samples available
we would be excited to help and to
analyze them
thank you dr bobby miller
thank you for your presentation today
and for your important research
and i also want to thank again all the
presenters dr hurwitz
davis dr voter miller all of you thank
you again
and i want to thank fluidine for
sponsoring today's event
before we go i also want to thank our
audience members for joining us
and reminding that questions submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed via the speaker
the contact information we provided at
the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through september
of 2021. until next time take care
stay healthy bye